hello friends and welcome back to rabbit  fire language learning today we're  exploring the question should i take a  language exam  now it all depends on your objectives  and your goals but in general we tend to  see these exams as something stressful  or even expensive and we tend to avoid  them the reality is that these language  tests can be incredible a language  learning tool so do not see it just do  not see a language test just as an event  where you get judged and you get good or  bad marks but see it as a possibility as  a chance to improve your language skills  set up a date buy a  some material to prepare for the exam go  through the material  test yourself keep learning and then  take the exam it doesn't matter whether  when you set the exam you pass it or not  the most important thing is actually the  learning process itself if you want to  know more about how to learn a language  more efficiently and with more fun  please check out my channel over and out